in addition to using the media tribute
on a linked stylesheet there are two
other ways you can apply media queries
you can embed them with an @ media tag
or you can embed them with an @ import
tag for performance reasons you
definitely want to avoid at import it's
pretty expensive and perfmatters you'll
need to weigh the cost between linked
CSS and @ media with linked CSS you've
got many small files but many HTTP
requests
whereas with @ media you've got fewer
requests but the files tend to be a
little bit bigger any filter that meets
the criteria of the resulting CSS block
will be applied using the standard CSS
rules of precedents that means when the
viewport is less than 500 pixels no
styles are applied but above 500 pixels
my body color becomes orange and above
800 pixels not only do I have the orange
text but I also have the blue background
I'm pretty sure that also means I've got
some pretty bad tasting colors